foreign
hey everyone we all know ethereum has
undergone a significant update one
dubbed as the single most significant
event in crypto history the update would
completely restructure blockchain
technology the world's second largest
blockchain infrastructure after an event
known as the merge the blockchain
network which presently uses the proof
of work algorithm that drives Bitcoin
and other cryptos we'll move to proof of
State consensus top crypto fund bitwise
Asset Management has hailed this upgrade
as the year's most intriguing narrative
in the digital asset market so here's a
video by simply learn on ethereum merge
to understand how this new Evolution of
ethereum will affect and grow the crypto
world
in this video we will learn what is the
ethereum merge followed by the benefits
of the merge and then we will put light
on what will happen to eth2 and at the
end we will understand the relationship
between these upgrades
so the first thing is to understand
ethereum merge and why it came into
existence
the merge brought together ethereum's
initial execution layer and its newest
proof of State consensus layer the
beacon chain it made it redundant to
mine cryptocurrency which used a lot of
energy and allowed the network to be
protected with State eth instead adding
greater scalability security and
sustainability was a very exciting step
toward achieving the ethereum mission in
the beginning mainnet and the beacon
chain were sent separately proof of work
continued to be used to secure the
ethereum mainnet which includes all of
its accounts balances smart contracts
and blockchain information while Beacon
chain operated in parallel using proof
of stake now these two systems came
together for the first time during the
merge and proof of stake eventually took
the place of proof of work but this
raises the question of why exactly it
came into existence and the benefits it
provides the two most important issues
that ethereum merge primarily focuses on
are energy consumption and scaling
ethereum's proof of work era ended with
the merge ushering in a more
environmentally friendly and
long-lasting ethereum energy use for
ethereum decreased by an estimated
99.95 percent making it a green
blockchain find out more about the
energy uses of ethereum also the merged
paved the way for more scalability
improvements that would not have been
feasible under proof of work moving
ethereum one step closer to reaching the
full-scale security and sustainability
described in its ethereum Vision but now
that ethereum merge is active what will
happen to eth2
now the phrase eth2 has been phased out
there is just ethereum now that eth1 and
eth2 have been combined into a single
chain eliminating the need to
distinguish between the two ethereum
networks to limit confusion the
community has updated these terms first
eth1 is now the execution layer which
handles transactions and execution and
eth2 is now the consensus layer which
handles proof of stake consensus but
these terminological updates solely
affect naming standards they have no
impact on ethereum's objectives or
development roadmap
well now that we have understood the
existence of ethereum merge now is the
time to understand the internal
relationship between these upgrades
so all of ethereum upgrades are
connected in some way so let's review
the connections between the merge and
the other enhancements
first the merge and the beacon chain
well the beacon chain is now efficiently
the replacement consensus layer for the
original mainnet execution layer as of
the merge since the merge the ethereum
mainnet is secured by validators mining
based on proof of work is no longer an
accepted block generation method instead
validating nodes that have staked eth in
return for the ability to participate in
consensus proposed blocks future
scalability improvements like sharding
are made possible by these modifications
second is the merge and the Shanghai
upgrade
the merge upgrade does not include
several anticipated functionalities such
as the ability to withdraw staked eth to
streamline and optimize focus on a
successful transition to proof of stake
the merge which will allow investors to
withdraw is scheduled to be followed by
the Shanghai upgrade
and the third one is the merge and
sharding before the merge efforts on
sharding were initially intended to
solve scalability
however with the popularity of layer 2
scaling Solutions switching from proof
of work to proof of stake first became
more important plans for sharding are
rapidly changing but given the
development and popularity of layer 2
Technologies to scale transaction
execution the focus of sharding plans
has shifted to determining the best
method for Distributing the burden of
storing compressed call data from
roll-up contracts enabling a rapid
increase in network capacity without
switching to proof of stake first this
would not be viable well this was all
about ethereum merge so what are your
opinions on this step of ethereum merge
I hope you like this video and found it
interesting and informative and if you
like this video then please like the
video and do subscribe to our YouTube
channel and also if you have any
questions related to this video please
feel free to ask in the comments section
our team will reach out to you as soon
as possible thank you you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here